india is in the grip of a second wave of
covid19
and nowhere is that being felt more than
in its hospitals
there are shortages of beds oxygen
supplies and medicine
and doctors say this time they've seen a
change in who is being admitted to
hospital
what we are seeing and this is all
anecdotal
uh a personal experience is there are
younger patients who are being admitted
into hospital
and are more sick than the
type of disease that young patients
usually have which is mild to moderate
india reported 275 000 new cases on
monday
that's the highest daily tally in a
country that's now the second worst
affected in the world scientists say a
new variant with a double mutation may
be driving up
infections in most cases we've only seen
one area of the virus mutating from the
original virus
in this case we have two separate
mutation sites
which is really concerning because as
you know you know every time that we
have a mutation we're worried about
increased transmissibility increased
threat of death
and a lack of ability of our vaccines to
work
despite the rise in cases political and
religious gatherings are continuing in
many places
last week three million hindu pilgrims
bathed in the ganges river for the
kummela festival
and millions more voted in local
elections in the state of uttar pradesh
i think the guard was let down not just
by
indians but by indian leaders
massive election rallies were held
and subsequently the massive hindu
festival
of whom all are contributing
towards this massive surge
around 120 million indians have so far
been inoculated
in a country of more than 1.3 billion
and with a new variant with a double
mutation to contend with
india faces many difficult days ahead
victoria gatenbee al jazeera